foreign
welcome welcome welcome to another
edition of Market takes today we are
breaking down the latest U.S retail
sales report uh it seems like the start
of what I've decided to call soft
Landing Summer uh we got soft Landing
Summer going on right now we're going to
take a look I'm gonna explain to you
what that means I'm just gonna leave it
out there but a retail sales report that
I think has got a lot of folks out there
in the markets excited we're going to
break all that down we're going to talk
about what this U.S retail sales report
showed how that compared to expectations
uh we're gonna of course talk about the
market reaction going to take you
through how markets reacted to this
report we're going to talk about
earnings and how this earnings season
what we've seen so far has kind of
really locked in the report and what the
report showed and really backed that in
terms of what investors are thinking
about the market and the economy um and
then we're going to talk about the FED
meeting because of course we know that
everything is based on the fed and
that's why when we talk about soft
Landing Summer that's really what it's
all about it's all about these
expectations for for the Federal Reserve
and what they're going to do at their
meeting next week of course we'll be
here on Market takes we hope you'll be
with us as well last thing we're going
to talk about what comes next because we
are always looking forward even though
it is backward looking data so first
things first let's talk about today's
report and the numbers that we saw I
want to throw up here on your screen a
chart of what we've got from the retail
sales report now what you see there is
on the right of your screen you see
three straight positive reports today's
report was 0.2 percent increase month
over month so June sales Rising 0.2
percent from May May was actually
revised higher so you had a point five
percent increase in May and so you see
those numbers over there on the right
looking pretty healthy after we had seen
four of the last seven uh reports coming
in being negative and you see those two
bars there going lower and then you see
that big increase in January before that
we had two negative reports so there was
some worry that we were going to
continue on this downward trajectory
that we had reached this place where we
were just moving lower that retail sales
were going to be negative that was
definitely a bad thing for retailers a
bad thing for the economy but what we
have seen the past three months is a
reversal of that Trend now want to
direct your attention to a different
chart I want to put the year over year
change up here on your screen in terms
of what we're seeing on retail sales and
what you see there is a bit of a
different picture you see that retail
sales number just going consistently
down and when we talk about soft Landing
Summer this is what we're talking about
now this is comparing to a year before
you see those numbers there on the left
side of your screen those are going high
above 10 percent above 15 percent then
you see us kind of come down and the big
thing about retail sales is retail sales
don't take inflation out of the picture
so as we're seeing inflation come down
we've seen those retail sales numbers
come down and that's what the Federal
Reserve wants to see when we talk about
a soft Landing well this is what they
want to see they don't want to see those
numbers going negative turning bad and
then the economy goes lower and folks go
out of business they start laying people
off no no know what the Federal Reserve
wants to see is exactly what you're
seeing up there on your screen which is
those numbers start to come down retail
sales start to reduce lower you start to
see a deceleration into maybe a Slowdown
and then the economy can kind of start
to pick back up as we move back towards
two percent inflation so you don't
really want to see Zero you don't only
want to see negative what you want to
see is the number for June is 1.5
percent so you've got a 1.5 increase
again it's from that number on the far
left side of your screen so what we have
seen is a is a small increase from a
very high number and those base effects
are going to start to play a real big
role as we move forward and as we
continue because you see as you see
there on your screen the numbers are
lower so we'll have a lower number to
compare to when we get into September
October those fall numbers because
inflation was declining retail sales
were declining but from what we're
seeing right now we are seeing just the
sales slow down not stop not crash not
move to a strong negative print but just
slow down to a slower increase a slower
pace of increase so retail sales still
picking up on a year-over-year basis but
again this just illustrating that we are
seeing this slow down and again what I'm
terming soft Landing Summer if you hear
that anywhere else they stole it from me
we came up with it right here on Market
takes first don't forget don't sleep on
us here at Market takes listen when
we're looking at where consumers are
spending right because we've got to dig
into these numbers a little bit to find
out okay what is this really saying to
us even those numbers are pretty
positive in terms of what it means for
the Federal Reserve so we saw spending
online continuing really leading all
categories for the monthly gain of 1.9
percent month over month and up 9.4
percent almost 10 percent year over year
so those online sales what they call
non-store retailers staying strong bars
and restaurants the service industry
well that is still positive up point one
percent month over month but up 8.4
percent year over year so looking very
similar to the overall chart we are
seeing Services inflation as in what
you're paying for services like when you
go out to a bar and get a drink when you
go out to a restaurant people serve you
when you go get your haircut at the
barber shop or go to the auto mechanic
we're seeing that really holding up
inflation but what you don't want is for
it to be pushing inflation too high
which is what we were seeing last year
and earlier in this year which is the
the inflation rate and the sales rate
because we know when people are going
out spending money they're buying by and
buying well we know prices are going up
and if people are paying those high
prices the prices just continue to
escalate and that's not what the FED
wants to see that's not what you and I
want to see those higher prices we don't
want that we want inflation to come down
and really get those price increases
more in control see that deceleration
one big surprise I think in terms of the
positive side was the the big increase
in furniture and Home Furnishing sales
up 1.4 percent month over month but down
4.6 percent year over year so furniture
and all and those things Home
Furnishings
had been declining pretty consistently
and then this month you saw a kind of
surprise pickup 1.4 month over month
increase we'll see if that's just kind
of a one month blip maybe things got off
the off on a weird track maybe you know
Big Mike's Furniture Warehouse had a big
sale and that just pushed the date up
but what we are seeing is a notable
month-over-month increase that's also
down 3.2 percent over the last six
months so going against the trend is
basically what I'm saying for furniture
and Home Furnishings
um the biggest decreases gasoline
stations that has been consistent and
that's a lot of why you're seeing those
consumer sentiment numbers really take
off we saw the latest University of
Michigan consumer sentiment index push
way above expectations and a big part of
that has been the decline that we have
seen in gas prices well we know when gas
prices go down Gas Stations don't make
as much money and that was down 1.4
month over month 22.7 percent year over
year so gas station Revenue really just
diving lower and that's again that's not
good if you're a gas station owner but
that's great great for the average
person who's got to you know fill up the
truck to get to work or fill up the car
to get to work and they're spending less
on gas stations than they were about 23
percent less than they were a year ago
Sporting Goods hobby musical instrument
and some books those down one percent
month over month about 1.3 year over
year building materials garden supplies
also down the big picture here is Goods
versus Services we know that goods are
falling because we're just not spending
as much going out and buying things like
you know tables air conditioners stuff
like that for our house and we're
spending more on Services going out
having a good time but what the Federal
Reserve does not want to see is too many
people going out and pushing those
Services prices way up that's not what
we're seeing in this report overall
you're not seeing a major acceleration
in Services data that would contrast or
offset the decline we're seeing in Goods
prices so good prices declining Services
holding up and that's holding those
retail sales numbers above above flat
above zero at 1 point five percent year
over year point two percent month over
month like we saw this month so that's
the big picture takeaway when it comes
to this report now let's take a look at
what we're seeing from the markets and I
want to direct your attention to the big
picture overview we're seeing some
mentioning things happen in the stock
market I think much more a a reaction to
the earnings reports that we've seen but
want to throw up here on your screen the
market reaction that we're seeing so
this is the big picture overview what
you're seeing there is the NASDAQ that's
negative overall on the day but the Dow
is up about point three four percent the
S P 500 about flat so what we're seeing
is a mixed reaction like I said I think
the NASDAQ is reacting to some of those
Bank earnings we saw actually a number
of smaller banks are in the NASDAQ and
the earnings reports we saw this morning
a bit of a mixed picture but those
bigger Banks and some of those big
picture things that it says about the
economy as in and I'll talk to you a
little bit about that later we won't get
too much into that now but I think
that's why you're seeing the reaction
from the stock market when we look at
bonds another interesting thing I saw
and let's I want to direct your
attention here to the 30 year bond yield
and what you're seeing there right a
pretty limited reaction the data came
out around eight o'clock so that's right
around this area when we're talking
about reaction so pretty minimal right
10-year you see about the same thing as
we get lower in yield you start to see a
bigger reaction from that data but then
that filtered out so five year you're
seeing an even bigger reaction right
down here boom you see this take off
around the three year even bigger
reaction the two-year which is most
closely tallied or most closely aligned
with expectations for what the Federal
Reserve will do you did see a big
reaction but that is kind of petered out
of the data let's talk really quickly
about currencies not much reaction here
from the data but did see an interesting
reaction I thought from Bitcoin we look
up here at Bitcoin a big turn down after
that data we don't know if that's
necessarily related it could be it may
not be Bitcoin obviously much more
traded by big take by Big Time Wall
Street investors these days than it was
but still often its own story and as you
see right there a big pickup in crude
oil that we've seen recently this wasn't
really in response to the data but a
pretty solid increase but you're seeing
across the board except for copper one
place you might want to look at okay if
there's something to worry about those
copper prices lower but not a big
reaction from the data and this really
just kind of illustrating the reaction
or maybe lack of a big reaction to this
data because a lot of this was priced in
right the reason that we're calling it
soft Landing Summer and not soft Landing
June or soft Landing retail sales report
because the data is pretty consistently
backed this theme that things are
starting to slow down inflation slowing
down job gains slowing down retail sales
slowing down not falling off a cliff not
halting not you know backing up and
turning negative but just slowing down
doing exactly what Fed chair Jerome
Powell said he wants to see from this
data that's exactly what we're getting
let's talk really quickly about the
earnings reports that we saw that we've
gotten today and then going back to last
week because they have really backed the
story of again this soft Landing Summer
and perhaps a pickup and accelerate that
gets the economy kicked back into gear
that could be good that could be bad but
we'll talk about it and cross that
bridge when we come to it Bank earnings
so far have shown increases in loan
defaults but still we are historically
low so we're seeing loan loss revisions
increase just a little bit that's Banks
saying hey you know we're a little
worried about what's going on we're
going to put a little more money to the
side just in case people aren't able to
pay back their loans but they're not
doing that at a big scale they're not
doing it in a big way so we are seeing
just a little bit of caution customers
at JP Morgan uh Wells Fargo Citigroup
spent more on credit cards more
borrowers carrying over those balances
I've been telling you all for months to
watch those credit balances but those
numbers in terms of the comparison to
the previous month have been declining
we are seeing lower use in terms of
month over month still year over year
you're seeing a pretty big pickup in
terms of credit folks still borrowing
money to pay for things that could be
worrisome in the long run because we
have seen the price of credit or those
interest rates on credit cards continue
to rise and we are still at historically
high levels but right now we're not
seeing defaults we're not seeing folks
not paying back their debt and the banks
really reconfirmed that and reiterated
that for us Citigroup CEO Jane Fraser
said quote overall I'd say we are seeing
a more cautious consumer but not
necessarily a recessionary one again
we're talking about it soft Landing
Summer Morgan Stanley reported earnings
just this morning really kind of their
CEO James Gorman kind of reiterating the
same thing their quarter their second
quarter profit fell 13 but they were
hurt by a they were hurt a lot by the
decline in trading Revenue not
necessarily anything in terms of their
consumers uh CEO James Gorman saying
quote saying sorry this isn't a quote
but a a summation of what he said client
activity was subdued to start the
quarter but ended on a stronger note we
were seeing that really across the board
we heard that from JP Morgan in their
earnings we heard that from CEO or from
Citigroup CEO Jane Fraser really a
pickup overall at the end folks are
starting to turn a corner in terms of
their confidence in the economy and we
are seeing that overall Bank earnings
show Americans Bank balances and how
they're spending their money and we have
learned the consumer really is an okay
shape right now not anything to be
worried about slowing down more cautious
those are good things right that's what
the FED wants to see the other
interesting thing though as we talk
about and we move to what's going on
with the FED investors still very much
expecting the Federal Reserve to raise
rates at its meeting this month that's
going to be next week and we'll we'll
talk about that here in just a second
but this really telling us that things
are slowing down they're not screeching
to a halt and that there's not really
anything that you should be worried
about this is exactly what the Federal
Reserve wants again that's what the data
tells us so far so right now where we
are seems like a good place let's talk
about the FED meeting right now right
now when we look at the FED funds
Futures Market investors have placed a
97 likelihood that the Federal Reserve
will raise rates at its next meeting so
want to put up here a chart on your
screen to just give you an idea of where
we are right you see those fed rates
this is the Fed funds rate where we are
over there on the right of your screen
this is as high as we've been really at
any time in the past 20 years this chart
going all the way back to 2000 and you
see there we are approaching those
levels those highs of 2008 those rates
were kept there for not very long and
then the FED had to start cutting as we
were going into that recession but
historically we are at a very high level
in terms of where the FED has rates and
the FED is again expected to hike a 97
likelihood among investors that they
will raise rates again in a week on July
26th we hope you'll be right here on
Market takes where we break down that
decision break down the press conference
and all that but just want to put this
chart up here on your screen to
illustrate where we are and where we've
come from and we have now gotten very
high up on the FED funds rate and that's
just kind of where we are so we took
when we look out at this upcoming fed
meeting I think this report along with
some of the other data is gonna
potentially give folks a reason to say
hey why are you guys trying to raise
rates again we we got soft Landing
Summer happening already why are you
guys raising rates uh but that's what
the FED is locked in they've really
locked in the market and it would be a
very big surprise if they did not raise
rates by 25 basis points at their next
meeting coming up next Wednesday so
you're going to want to watch out for
that I think this definitely locks in
rates investors were expecting just one
increase this year and that's going to
be in July and then really the market is
predicting the FED will not raise rates
again for the rest of the year going all
the way up to December this certainly
locks that in and really I think
cemented those expectations and also
though the question becomes is the Fed
now doing too much those folks who have
already said you know what the FED
shouldn't have raised rates this high
they shouldn't have done it they are
going to be louder now as you hear from
them oh we'll look at retail sales that
report's already coming in it's already
coming down we already got soft Landing
Summer what are you guys doing that's
going to be an interesting debate and we
will see how that plays out
um what comes next well the earnings
reports keep coming this week we get
Tesla Netflix United Johnson Johnson a
whole host of others you're going to
want to watch those because I think
those are going to tell us a lot about
the economy the FED meeting next week
will be highly watched not for what the
FED does but for what the FED says we
will be here 4 pm Eastern uh doing
Market takes on Wednesday I hope you'll
be with us there for Market takes uh the
second quarter GDP report comes out that
will be tightly watched because of how
much GDP for the first quarter was
raised over expectations
and we could be seeing a repeat of that
in the second quarter number and of
course we'll be talking about all that
on Monday doing our look ahead for
Market take so listen I am Dion Robert
Bowen reporter for the Wall Street
Journal appreciate you guys being with
us and you hope we hope that you'll do
it with us and be with us again next
time
um
[Music]